here's a fun little problem if x is
greater than 0 and x plus 1 over X is
equal to 5 then find the value of root X
plus one over root X
to work this out imagine squaring the
result
we have the square root X plus two times
the product of the terms plus the square
of 1 over root X
the first term works out to be X then
the product of these terms will cancel
out to be one so the second term will be
two finally the square of 1 over root X
is equal to 1 over X so we add these
terms together but now we can rearrange
the terms so we have X plus one over X
plus two but we know that X plus one
over X is equal to five so this is equal
to five plus two which means the square
is equal to seven
since X is greater than zero we know
root X plus one over root X will be a
positive number so we take the positive
square root of both sides to get root X
plus one over root X is equal to root
seven